- [Narrator] Primetime game shows,
(game show host speaks Chinese)
(contestant speaks Chinese)
- [Narrator] military parades,
(soldiers chant)
and bookstores with dedicated sections
to the writings of
Chinese leader Xi Jinping.
These are some of the ways
China's propaganda machine
has elevated Xi's standing
to levels unseen in decades.
(Xi speaks Chinese)
(crowd applauds and cheers)
- [Narrator] Over his 10 years as leader,
Xi has tried to orchestrate
the country's rise
as a global superpower,
despite the recent slowdown in the economy
and pushback from the West.
- He really has overturned
the way China has been governed.
- [Narrator] So as Xi prepares to secure
a third term as president,
we break down these three moments
along his path to becoming
one of China's longest-serving leaders.
Xi joined the Communist Party in 1971,
and steadily climbed through its ranks
over the next few decades.
In 2007, he rose to the national stage
when he joined the Politburo
Standing Committee,
a group of China's most senior officials.
- The party elite actually
was craving a strong leader.
(audience applauds)
When Xi Jinping came
to power in late 2012,
the party's power brokers
got what they wanted,
and then some.
- [Narrator] The new
leader's change in approach
was put on display right away,
when Xi visited the city of Shenzhen
to lay out his vision for the country.
And he chose a symbolic venue,
an exhibition called "The
Road to Rejuvenation."
In a highly orchestrated moment
that was broadcast on state TV,
Xi was surrounded
by some of China's most
historical objects.
- The display told the story
of China's rise from
subjugation to triumph
under the Chinese Communist
Party's leadership.
- [Narrator] And here,
Xi unveiled the name
for what would be the next
stage in China's story,
with him at its helm.
(Xi speaks Chinese)
- "China Dream" is a slogan
that conveys Xi Jinping's desire
to make China a global superpower
that is equal to the United States.
- [Narrator] In the
early stages of his rule,
Xi tried to make China's economy more open
and driven by market forces.
- He actually laid out
this very ambitious
economic reform program,
which called for state companies
to operate more like commercial firms,
and for the government to
promote entrepreneurship.
- [Narrator] He also shattered
taboos in Chinese politics
by targeting party elders
in a wide-ranging
anti-corruption campaign,
which ended up being
popular with the public.
- He honed a very
paternalistic public image
as Xi Dada, or Big Papa Xi.
- [Narrator] And Xi also
challenged the US more forcefully
than his predecessors.
Xi's territorial ambitions
in regions including the South China Sea,
and economic programs such as
the Belt and Road Initiative,
began to clash with US interests.
- His China Dream also meant
putting China on a collision
course with the United States,
as China, you know, strove to be
a rival economically,
militarily, and politically.
- [Narrator] And this collision
was about to come to a head
when Xi invited President
Donald Trump to visit Beijing.
- I remember on Trump's
first day in Beijing,
Xi Jinping and his wife
escorted Trump and his wife
on a private tour of the Forbidden City.
- [Narrator] Xi's plan
was to charm his rival
and calm the simmering tensions
created during his leadership.
- There can be no more important subject
than China-US relation.
- Xi Jinping tried to convince him
that there's still so much to gain
from having a good
relationship with Beijing.
But it didn't really work.
- [Narrator] A few months after the visit,
the US imposed a series of
tariffs and trade barriers
on China.
Washington said it was in response
to unfair trade practices and
intellectual property theft.
This began a trade war
that upended markets
and reshaped global commerce.
- The trade war lasted two
years, and both sides cut a deal.
It didn't really help
improve the relationship.
- [Narrator] The trade deal
was only a temporary truce.
Soon after it was signed,
the coronavirus pandemic began,
sinking the relationship even further.
- This horrible thing that
was delivered by China,
and it was by China,-
- [Narrator] The US President blamed China
for unleashing the virus,
a charge Beijing vehemently denied.
The growing schism between the countries
only made Xi look more powerful at home,
as the man who had stood up to the US.
And he ensured that he
would remain at the top
by removing term limits in 2018,
paving the way for him to become
China's president-for-life.
- He tried to roll back
China's decades-long evolution
toward Western-style,
you know, capitalism.
This different path is
basically socialism,
you know, in the spirit of Mao Zedong.
- [Narrator] And the spirit
of Mao was on full display
in 2021, at the Communist
Party's centennial celebration
in Tiananmen Square.
- We saw the TV footage of Xi Jinping
wearing this Mao suit,
and standing behind this, you know, podium
adorned with hammer and sickle.
("The Internationale")
- [Narrator] After a speech, Xi sang along
to "The Internationale," a socialist song
that, in China, has long
symbolized declarations of war
by the working class on capitalism.
And it soon became clear
that this war was being waged
at some of China's most
valuable tech companies.
- Private technology firms
have grown tremendously in recent years,
but increasingly are seen
as challenging Xi Jinping's
authoritarian rule.
(Jack Ma speaks Chinese)
- [Narrator] For Xi, they were
gaining too much influence
in areas like finance,
entertainment, and digital gaming.
- It was almost like a 180-degree turn.
He now is trying to further enhance
the role of the state, the
government, in running economy.
- [Narrator] But even as Xi has continued
to concentrate his power
over the past decade,
he's also faced challenges,
from the pro-democracy
movement in Hong Kong
to Covid lockdowns that
have added pressure
to an economic slowdown
weighed by a battered property market.
And as Beijing and Washington
continue to compete for global influence,
Xi is carrying on with his dream
of making China a superpower.
- As far as he is concerned,
China's time has arrived.